let me give a shout out here to chris
haynes nba on tnt
courtside reporter that means he gets
dressed up to go to the games yahoo
sports nba insider and host of
posted up with chris haynes podcast he
covered lakers blazers monday mavs
clippers last night
so let me start with mavs and the
clippers good morning chris
do you think the nba does anything to
marcus morris after what happened to
luka doncic last night
it would be hard for them to to find out
that marcus
you know did that on purpose i've seen
i've seen the um the replay obviously
and i've seen it live
and you know it does look questionable
but it's just it's just hard to tell i i
don't understand how the nba can come
down with a ruling saying that marcus
intentionally intended to step on the
the ankle or the foot of luka doncic and
that's that's a serious matter
obviously lucas is back out there you
know by himself when you look at look at
it from a star
perspective and you know he's hobbled
and so for anybody to do that that is
that's definitely an egregious act
but i i just can't see how the nba rules
down on marcus
yeah it's tough to rule on intent and
i'm with you on that but
when i watch it marcus morris is not
making a basketball play there's no
reason for him to be approaching luca
from behind
because they just scored the basket and
he goes over
i thought he was going to like elbow it
or like give him a forearm or something
like nudge him a little bit
and you happen to step on the bad ankle
i i'm not gonna
and plus this is marcus morris if this
is kawhi who did it i'd give him the
benefit of the doubt morris doesn't get
the benefit of the doubt here
yeah and look and marcus has been
roughing up luca you know especially
after luke had those you know tremendous
games
he's been roughing my body and i'm
trying to make sure he's getting all up
in them
um talking trash and luca said he's
saying luke even said it last night
marcus is saying all type of you know
foul stuff at me but i'm trying to
ignore them so
this is attack that that marcus morris
is using again
i know he's trying to get all up in him
i know he's trying to rough him up you
know
and bother him but again i i just
it's just difficult for us to tell
intent the clippers look great what was
the biggest difference last night
aside from kristops not playing and then
luca being shut down
and you know maybe that ankle has a
little bit to do with it but
what's the difference with the clippers
i mean playoff p
showed up
play off p shoulder i mean that was
pretty much the difference you know he
hit the first basket of the game
well you can tell uh that that was his
mission
to be offensively assertive and uh i
think once he did
that kind of rallied the troops and uh
you know they just got it going they had
it going from the start
you know you know really there was a lot
of different elements but paul george
definitely i think i was a difference
maker
but then after the game he talked about
being depressed and
you know being in the bubble and it got
to him and
said because i wondered was he injured
was there something else going on here
because
he just seemed like he was not all there
and then he said
i was actually going through something
in the bubble you
how surprised were you with that i was
surprised to hear him say that
um i'm not necessarily surprised if that
was really the reason
why he was struggling you know there's a
you know there's a bunch of players
who are having their their eos here in
the bubble
just trying to cope with um not being
around family
um the things that's going on in society
right now another unarmed
black man shot and this one happened in
wisconsin
in front of his kids and so there's a
lot of guys that's dealing with these
things and
you know you're used to after games
going home and
whether that's a bad game good game or
whether you're dealing with certain
problems you're used to going on and
being
around family being around people that
you love people that that support you
and
can give you guidance um that's not here
uh
you know teammates are teammates and
definitely there's a bond between
teammates but
it's not your family it's not what
you're accustomed to to going home to
and so
that's been an issue for everybody but i
am surprised that paul george did reveal
that
but then you had this uh you know
senseless
shooting with uh jacob blake and the
players at least it felt like
there was the start of a groundswell
that maybe they were going to try to do
something whether it's
sit out a game uh there'd be a boycott
uh
how close do you think we are or were to
something like that happening in the
bubble
well i just reported about 10 minutes
ago uh
for yahoo sports that um there was
actually a meeting held
last night there was a gathering with
players
um who are just emotionally distraught
and traumatized
over what is going on they're hurting
here in this bubble and a
group of them met um at one of the
hotels here on campus and
they met with um chris paul was there
andre iguodala you know as a leadership
committee of the players association and
basically they're trying to get guidance
and get some of the logistics of
what it would look like if they were the
boycott trying to figure out their
options and
it was it was a good talk from what i
was told and
a lot of guys are just frustrated
because they felt like a lot of things
that
they plan to do like players plan before
they got here they plan to
have meetings weekly um they want to
have a couple meetings weekly just to
kind of
stay engaged and and just brainstorm
what they can do
but those meetings haven't come about as
frequently as they hope because as you
know there's games every day
practices every other day film study and
so
they're feeling like a lot of players
are frustrated because they feel like
the the thing is that they're coming
over here and they're
distracting away from the real issues
that are going on in the black community
and that is what they fear from the get
so those talks are still ongoing they
started
yesterday they had a significant meeting
last night
trying to get the logistics so this is
something that's ruined
and that's something that i don't know
that it's going to get done
but there's definitely the talks are
firm and it's definitely real how much
pressure is on lebron
because usually when he says something
does something
you know he's become sort of the de
facto league spokesperson
uh lebron has made it clear from day one
even before he got to the to orlando
that he felt that
the nba must go on we must get this
season
and so pressure on him i don't know
necessarily that there's pressure
aside from just trying to perform on the
court
um look i this season i will believe
this season
is going to to continue on i don't know
what's going to happen in the short term
as far as boycotting games or so but uh
i don't i don't see there being pressure
but i will say this dan you know there
are people
players and significant um agents
who told the players look before we got
to this restart
that look we can boycott or we can
choose not to go this restart but
how beneficial if it is is it to us
to lose money and that's going to only
hurt
our chances of being able to invest in
the black community
and being able to give back so a lot of
people are saying a lot of players feel
like
you know boycotting or not playing
that's going to hurt the black community
that's going to hurt our pockets
enabling us to give back
so that's the other side of that
equation i think that's what
lebron james leans on as well we're
talking to chris haynes nba on tnt
courtside reporter and of course yahoo
sports
nba insider host of the posted up with
chris haynes
podcast lakers fixed all their issues
they're all good right now
in this series especially especially
with damian lillard out
they they definitely they've definitely
fixed it uh
you know for this series but you know
look the lakers have never been a good
three-point shooting team
all season they were one of the poorest
teams in the league over the last
few games you know they've been one of
the best is that going to be sustainable
and then when rajon rondo gets gets back
you know can they keep that up
so um i think they've solved it solved
it for right now i'll be
very very surprised not to disrespect
use of nurkies not to disrespect cj
mccullum
carmelo anthony but i would be very
surprised if the blazers were able to
extend it to game six i just don't think
they have to fire power in the depth
to continue with the lakers right now
who would the lakers want to face
between the rockets or thunder
the thunder i was i would say the
thunder i would say the thunder
i just think the matchups are a problem
you know uh oklahoma city has a small
guard
uh back court not just in the backcourt
you know even at the small four position
when they
put sheaths in over there so yeah okc
for sure
can you see greg popovich actually
taking the job in brooklyn
it's tough it's really tough it's really
tough for me to imagine that no no doubt
about it sean marx
has his eyes on greg popovich you know
one of his mentors
um but it's very tough you know for the
last
four years you know we've been kind of
hearing
papa's thinking about retiring you know
retire it's like every year like every
single year it's kind of like
jordan you know his last tenure you know
his last few years in the league
uh you just didn't know if he was going
to retire this is going to be the year
or not
so um i will say this um if pop did take
that next job
i can't see it happen i personally can't
see it happen but if he did
you know that's that's a situation where
it's a short term
uh a short-term fix because i think pop
can go in there
and transform that team into a
championship content team from day one
and so i can see a scenario of where it
would make sense but i i don't
i just can't see it i don't see it at
all yeah i wondered if he was going to
continue coaching and i thought that he
would eventually when he left the spurs
leave them
in a place of comfort that becky hammond
might take over as the head coach i
i don't know if tim duncan wants to be
the head coach but i thought knowing pop
and always forward thinking that he
would
he would welcome or try to usher in
becky hammond as the first female head
coach in nba history what do you think
about that
well that would be the ultimate move
that would be the ultimate assist
no definitely i i definitely see that if
pop
wants to if pop feels like becky is
ready
for this opportunity and then he can go
over there and get back
to playing high you know high level
basketball and get back to the
postseason because
as we know spurs didn't make it for the
first time in what two decades so
i i can see that it makes all the sense
in the world but it's just hard just to
not see
pop on the spurs sideline i don't know
if you know this story just came out
the pacers have fired nate mcmillan
they gave him a contract extension two
weeks ago
they put a year and they put they put a
year on his uh
on his car it was funny you know when it
came
out that he got an extension like okay
that's cool you know so that's important
we found out it was just a year added to
it so
oh yeah but i thought they were a
feel-good team and you had the
young players there and you know tj
warren was the michael jordan of the
bubble
you know i mean they got swept
so you know brett brown got swept
because i believe they got swept didn't
they get
yeah okay they got swept and and brett
around
there got swept and so you know that's
that's kind of
come to the territory got any bubble uh
gossip there for me
bubble gossip i mean i haven't seen
anybody sneak off
i haven't seen anybody um coming in as
well
and trying to think any juicy tidbits i
have for ezp
are you on late night patrol i'm not
but i i am up late nights and i find
myself walking around
uh you know not walking around see if i
see anything questionable just walk
around because
you're okay i just want to make sure
you got to make sure okay i just want to
make sure i don't you know
how's uh morale there uh look
i think morale is going to be a lot
better next week because uh
wives and and girlfriends get clear
and and and what's it called uh
california work
is that what it's la work l.a work
damn i love that i never i never knew
that
that term la work have you experienced
that
no no no i i mean back in the
the early 80s but i've been married 33
years so
i i have a hard enough time doing uh
milford work here man
don't get in trouble dp no no i actually
i
i get worked i i'm not
i'm not in the import export business
here chris i'm not
now i've been in a bubble before there
was the bubble
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us chris
all right all right that's chris haynes
nba
on tnt courtside report got him crying
i know i know